so let's say you want to get married in
washington dc
you can do that the authorities will
allow it but let's say you have a couple
drinks and want to move your feet you
can't do that because in washington dc
there is no dancing that's according to
the city's mayor muriel browser
here's what's getting a lot of attention
standing and dancing receptions are not
allowed
what good is a wedding without dancing
mayor and why no dancing
well i think there's a lot of good to a
wedding like people
starting off their their lives together
and doing it in a safe way
uh and not doing it in a way that puts
themselves or their guests in danger but
mayor just just is there any way that
you would reconsider with masks on
and say a card that shows fully
vaccinated that you'd allow dancing
we're absolutely considering opening
more activity
as our case rates go down and our
vaccination rates go up
and that's in our hotels and that's in
our other venues
so when you might ask did muriel bowser
become an ayatollah
and in charge of whether you can dance
or not real bowser is one of the least
impressive most irrational political
leaders in the history of the country
her order is among other things stupid
and crazy
oh but no her fellow democrats popped up
leaders in illinois and michigan who
have similar bans to say
she's great meanwhile the governor of
new mexico has come out
to call her courageous
is there dancing allowed in new mexico
governor
well i'll tell you what if you're
socially distanced and you're wearing a
mask and you meet the other
uh requirements with our level of
vaccinations um
yes right and then so
i want to give the mayor uh it takes
courage
to be really clear about what
constitutes high-risk
activities and behaviors so if you're
wearing a mask and you're socially
distanced and you're
vaccinated then possibly we will allow
you to dance
now as an epidemiological matter that's
ridiculous
but no says the deeply mediocre dumb
governor of new mexico
that's courageous and at cena and that's
all very normal because weddings are
needless to say
super spreader events
yesterday some news reader at cnn
interviewed a woman who'd like to get
married in washington d.c soon and that
woman pleaded with the ayatollah mayor
to reconsider her anti-dancing ordinance
okay julian let me just challenge you a
little bit here you know that
weddings have been super spreader events
what were you planning to do
for precautions
for sure and really the safety of all of
our guests
should be the number one priority so i
really think at this point there's a
reasonable solution for this
we were planning to all wear masks this
entire time during the wedding
and you know if dc wants to meet halfway
and allow standing dancing mingling i
mean we can even
require a negative covid19 test or show
a vaccination card
the most important thing about the
wedding is the safety of the guests now
the most important thing about the
wedding
is the wedding it's the marriage between
a man and a woman
and if that's too dangerous for you
don't come and if you're worried get
vaccinated
then you have to care if anyone else has
been vaccinated because you're
vaccinated vaccines work right
oh no since the news reader said oh
we're a mess socially just show your
vaccine
it used to be that only religious
crazies the extremists on the radical
right
were against dancing there was a whole
movie about it back in 1984.
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else